mark can you share with us your use of
two narrators yes these the story I just
told you about my tenth birthday was
told mostly in the past tense
now what we will do and someone says
asks you something and you're about to
tell an autobiographical story or you
want to tell a story or you want to tell
someone about what you just witnessed or
you saw a week or two ago you will by
instinct and there's a lot of reasons
for this tell it in the past tense you
will say okay it was last Wednesday and
I was driving my car on the freeway and
then I saw and it's in the past tense
now as soon as you are telling the story
in the past tense the listener
automatically knows several things they
know that you know the ending of the
story now that sounds silly or maybe
dead a little confusing why wouldn't you
of course you do know the ending but
when you tell it in the past tense that
narrator talking the past tense and
knows the end of the story that narrator
also knows everything that's happened
since that story until the present
moment that's why we call it the
omniscient narrator the narrator who
knows everything I know the story I'm
going to tell you I know how it ends I
know everything that's happened since
then I know that we percussions of that
story I know everything so it actually
means that in the telling of the story
the story is like here and the
storyteller is here telling about this
thing and you the listener are there and
there's the story so this story is
separate from me the storyteller and
separate from you it's this entity that
exists by itself here then there's
another narrator and the other narrator
is is called the naive narrator and this
is a tricky one and very very powerful a
naive narrator tells the story in the
present tense
tells the story not only just in the
present tense but it's telling the story
from the point that the characters in at
the moment not knowing even what's going
to happen in the next few seconds so
rather than in the past it's okay it was
last Wednesday I was driving my car on
the 405
that's the omniscient narrator the naive
narrator I'm driving my car I'm on the
405 now it's in the present tense now
right that just the fact that you hear
it in the present tense shifts the whole
story because it sounds like I don't
know what's gonna happen I'm driving on
the 405 and I see this little yellow car
and it's zooming it's zooming up behind
me I can see it in my rearview mirror
now I can tell you all that you still
get the feeling that I don't know what's
going to happen although of course if
you're smart enough you say well mark is
telling me this story he's here in front
of me he must know how it's gonna end
but my feeling is he doesn't he doesn't
because he's put himself in the middle
of the story telling the story as it
happens he is totally totally naive now
Karen the story is not here with me here
the story is around me and it's actually
around you too you are in the middle of
the story I'm in the middle of the story
and quite honestly that's where you want
to be now think about this every
screenplay that you've ever read and I'm
assuming you've read a lot of them
they're all in the present tense they're
all in the present tense
Jim does this he does that he does this
he does that do you know why they're in
the present tense because when it's up
on the screen we want to believe it's
happening as we watch it now we as an
audience of film are smart enough to
know that we go to see a movie
we know they spent how many years
writing it how many months shooting it
huh you know all the work they've done
it's done it's finished
but we go and we watch it suspending
disbelief and I'll believing that that
what we are watching right now on the
screen is happening in the moment
because that's where we want to be so
the naive narrator can take us into the
center of the story so as you're telling
a story it's not which narrator you use
it's when you new use each narrator that
gives you control over the story in
other words I could be telling you the
story I'm making up this story about the
four or five it's just as good as
anything else I'm driving on the 405 405
and I'm feeling nervous because behind
me I see in this rearview mirror this
yellow car is coming at me and he's he
or she or whatever's going way too fast
and I'm really scared now that's all the
naive narrator and you are probably an
appointed going what's gonna happen
what's gonna happen now I as the
storyteller and this is the beauty of
being a storyteller I'm in total control
of this story and I at anytime I want
can pop you out of the story right now
you're in the middle of the story and I
can pop you out and anytime I want and I
can say the car is coming at me it's
coming faster and faster now you got to
understand something about me and yellow
cars you know the first car I ever
bought was a yellow station wagon it was
really an ugly car now what I just did
is I jumped to the other narrator I
jumped out of the story I jumped to the
other narrator I'm giving you some
information that I think you need to
have which will help inform the story
but I've left you hanging about what's
going on in the story and there's a part
of you go okay great information but
what's happening there okay I got it I
got it now I have you curious about two
things why am I getting this new
information and what's happening there
and then anymore Mike said and I look in
their rearview mirror and it's coming
closer and closer and closer and I can
see there's nobody driving it
there's nobody so I can switch back and
forth them as I switch back and forth
between those two narrators
I'm actually manipulating you I'm
bringing you into the story pulling you
out of the story bring you into the
story pull you out of the story it's all
part of the structure of the story that
I want to tell that's how I want to tell
it when playing with you and playing
with your relationship to the story do
we like being manipulated does the
audience I mean I realize that's a weird
way to say it but does that something we
like do you like roller coasters can I
don't you don't but I like movies but
you're like me I don't like roller
coasters look it but you did that so
that's right but I think there's sort of
a wonderful love-hate relationship with
being manipulated I don't want to be
manipulated and then we go through a
movie oh that's so scary it wasn't that
great and I think what you were just
manipulated I think we find our forms of
entertainment that manipulate us whether
it's roller coaster rides or a movie
that take us into danger take us into a
zone of danger where we feel we're at
risk roller coaster ride we could die
the feel that way sometimes in a movie
it's an emotional danger I'm going to
feel sad I'm gonna Veil hurt I'm gonna
feel scared but then you can we come out
good wow that was great I want to see
that again but I say you were scared you
were screaming out of fear so there's
this curious relationship we have my
feeling is when we go to see a movie or
we read a book or read or hear a story
being told is please please manipulate
me thrill me scare me dazzle me my only
caveat is don't bore me don't be boring
I don't mind movies that I hate because
I felt hate I hate this then I hate
these I don't mind characters that I
hate people say wasn't that what I hated
her whatever it is it doesn't matter
and all these characters and all these
stories they do manipulate us but the
worst thing is to go there's no point to
watching this there's nothing going on
this is just boring
that's the worst how do most people use
the naive narrator incorrectly and then
the omniscient narrator incorrectly
several things about the two narrators
you need to understand and how they can
be if they used incorrectly they just
won't be effective at all one thing
about the omniscient narrator the
omniscient narrator does know everything
the omniscient narrator since the
omniscient narrator is talking about an
event there and is actually that
narrator is not involved in the event
that narrator is only telling about the
event the mistake you can note do is say
okay I'm gonna tell this story and then
I'm going to get really emotional so
that the audience will know how
emotionally I was affected at that time
but you're still telling it in the past
tense and when she looked at me I wanted
to cry and then she did this and then
she did that and you know what we have
now therapy why am I telling the story
am i telling the story because I want to
go through those emotions again because
we can feel the audience can feel that
emotion is not connected with the story
that of that emotion is connected with
the memory of this story so the
emotional journey of the character does
not belong in that narrator it belongs
in the naive narrator now the naive
narrator just say you know and she's
looking at me and I'm really scared
now I'm in the present tense and I go
that's totally acceptable because you're
telling me what's going on and how
you're feeling which is also what's
going on in the moment but if the naive
narrator tries to put this into some
larger perspective I'm looking at her in
there you got to understand you know I
really had a lot of trouble with the
relationships for a long time you go
where are you going why are you thinking
about that in the middle of this this
moment with this woman why that's the
job of the omniscient narrator
the each have separate jobs and they
have to you have to be purely in one or
the other all the time
you